but first the pro-crime party
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now by all accounts uh bryson christian
was an amazing kid
he loved oreo cookies and spongebob
squarepants his dad said that the
two-year-old
was the kind of person who could just
light up a room
well tragically that light went out just
days ago
when bryson and his nine-year-old
brother bj
were shot on a detroit interstate and it
happened as their family was driving
home from baseball practice
now bj survived bryson was pronounced
dead at the hospital
less than 12 hours after that on
detroit's west side
another burst of violence an 11 year old
boy and his father were seriously
wounded
after their car was sprayed with bullets
then roughly i don't know about 530
miles or so away in baltimore
just yesterday a man was shot multiple
times
in the head in broad daylight
now that was charm city's second murder
that day
hours earlier a man was stabbed to death
in st
louis it was a deadly father's day
weekend and things didn't let up last
night
with seven shot and three dead in just
one neighborhood incident
but that's okay because i'm sure
residents there
are comforted by mayor tishara jones who
tweeted
after decades of neglect i'm committed
to reinvesting in north city
to address root causes of crime more
resources make
our community safer she did thoughts and
prayers as well
root causes more resources doesn't that
sound like kamala harris's answer on the
border crisis
of course the truth is these progressive
mayors these
socialist mayors are themselves drivers
of crime
from defund the police to eliminating
cash bail
to emptying our prisons the policies
they've advocated have made
urban areas unlivable violent cesspools
and of course now that crime is
skyrocketing because of their policies
they're blaming the very group they once
attacked for being too hard on criminals
this rising crime is not the fault of
the movement
it's actually the fault of the police
and this has been our point all along
why should we keep funding systems and
institutions
that keep rendering themselves
ineffective
after over a year of attacks by black
lives matter and democrats like
her and elon omar police departments
across the country
they're in crisis morale i think is at
an all-time low now
we're dealing with rioting at a level
and a sustained violence that we've
never seen before
we're looking at the most catastrophic
staffing levels we've ever seen before
several cities have faced calls to
defund the police others have slashed
budgets due to covet more and more
officers say
they feel villainized like never before
we've reached a breaking point
it all boils down to these three main
concepts of being
underfunded understaffed and under
supported
that was on msnbc but remember this is
exactly what liberals have always wanted
to me it was obvious since my first
criminal procedure class in law school
that
most democrats simply don't really
see violent crime as a law order problem
at all
they think crime is committed by people
who are misunderstood and oppressed
not by people who are threat but
if you're an evangelical christian who
owns a firearm and flies the american
flag
you're definitely a threat the fact is
crime is rampant because today's
democrats refuse to do
what we know works remember back in the
90s when crime was ravaging inner cities
there was a bipartisan agreement that
the safer streets that we wanted
required strong policing and tough
sentencing
today's democrats are ashamed of that
crime bill that bill clinton signed
and joe biden helped draft
that's not just mayor p but kamala
harris also came out
in strong opposition of joe biden's arc
you know architecture of the 1994
crime bill crime is a giant issue as joe
biden tries to navigate the then and now
of democratic politics how does he
structure
his justice department if he's president
that would give comfort to many people
of communities that were
disproportionately impacted by the crime
bill
where was uh reverend al in baltimore
today with all this hell breaking news
well today's democrat mayors are so
dishonest they're
actually pretending that there are no
solutions to the crime problem
this is the washington post today mayors
see few options for regaining control
increased killings may be here to stay
okay first of all that's just a blatant
lie
and it's a total setup for biden's
anti-gun push and the democrats general
push
to try to nationalize policing standards
in the united states
and of course we don't have a crime
problem because of bad cops or
because of covet or because of too many
guns we have a crime problem because
democrats only care about black lives
lost to violence
when the trigger is pulled by a police
officer then they exploit those
tragedies to gain political power
but what happened in baltimore and
detroit st louis over the weekend
that doesn't fit their narrative in fact
democrats know
their policies are going to lead to more
black and brown lives lost
and news flash they just don't care
closing the border stopping drug cartels
would stop crime
democrats don't care supporting da's who
get tough on thugs and gang bangers
that would stop crime but democrats
don't care
prosecuting violence and looting like we
saw in portland and seattle over the
past year
that would stop crime democrats don't
care
devoting federal resources to stop
deadly fentanyl in the same way
that they chase down powerless you know
ridiculous
ostracized white supremacists that would
stop crime
but democrats don't care and neither do
the media by the way because if they did
they'd spend more time with the victims
of inner city crime
and they'd highlight what works to stop
the violence
instead they aim to inflame
the more you kind of dive into that the
more i'm really realizing how deeply
rooted
racism is and to like my everyday
thought process a living embodied
anti-racist culture does not exist among
white people
white people together specifically
around race
white accountability groups are really
helpful there's a period of deep shame
for being white they're shame directed
all right at the washington post it was
just disgusting
but every once in a while a local
reporter
speaks to a real person who's just
trying to survive
i feel trapped and eventually i got off
right into the spine i'm supposed to be
out every 15 minutes four times a day to
walk
and i can't do it cause i'm scared i'm
damn tired of it i'm gonna tell you like
this
what's your message to the mayor and the
commission i want to get
together i mean you just got to do
something it's not fair
the left knows it's not fair to the
people of baltimore st
louis all across this country who are
suffering in the inner cities
in fact i'm getting to think that's all
part of the plan though for the
democrats because they're willing
to accept that old woman's suffering
even the deaths of toddlers like bryson
christian
if it means keeping minority communities
dependent
and scared there are many many good
people in these crime infested cities
and they see full well that rich white
liberals
don't give a you know what about them
rich lefties care about things like
legalizing pot and transgenderism and
abortion
on demand they don't care about black
lives in the inner city
americans don't have to live like this
no one in america
should have to live like this should
have to fear walking the streets of
their own neighborhood no one in america
should worry about whether the kids are
going to come home at night
then no one in america should be stuck
inside because they don't feel safe on
their own streets
voters across the country trapped in
these unfair cities
abandoned by their elected officials
they have to rise up and join our
movement
we know how to make the streets safe
again we know how to build good schools
we know how to create more jobs we're
doing it all over the country
these policies work they work in florida
and texas
and tennessee and south dakota and
beyond
and they'll work in detroit they'll work
in baltimore they'll work in st
louis they'll work in new york city and
hartford all over the country
anywhere else they're tried so let's
send the left
and the criminals packing and
let's make sure we have safe great
american cities again and that's the
angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else